representing the government this morning
is the care minister helen whaley hello
to you thanks for joining us on good
program i want to talk to you about care
obviously a big topic um this week but
first can i just ask you about those
migrant boats as much as you know um
are you really going to try and turn
them around well the first thing here to
remember is that migrants traveling on
those boats or other routes like that to
try and get to the uk are of course
desperate but we also know that's a
desperate dangerous way they're taking a
really perilous journey to come to the
uk so we want to deter people from
embarking on that kind of dangerous
journey you also know as they do it then
that puts money into the people's fungus
pockets those organized international
crime gangs so the big question is what
are the ways that we can do the measures
we can take to stop people getting into
votes and coming trying to get here this
way and actually we have a separate
approach to try and enable safe routes
to get here for asylum seekers so the
government has been looking at in a wide
range of options but particularly to
working with the french and for instance
an extra 54 million is used to go to the
french so that they can put in place
more border patrols and use more
technology to try and stop people
setting off in the first place are we
going to turn the boats around well i
know that the government looks at all
the options but i think a really
important thing of course is you
wouldn't want to put people in any
greater danger they're taking a
dangerous journey as it is and what we
want to do is actually deter them from
starting that journey in the first place
are we going to turn the boats around i
haven't got there's nothing more i can
say to you and that beyond knowing the
government is looking at all the options
do you think it's a good idea right to
do that i said i think one thing that's
really important because it's against
the law of course
really you can't do that is to think
about the safety actually we
we want um you know we don't want people
to have any more danger on a journey
they're taking to get here they need to
but overall turning them around
we want to do well i mean
the overall what we want to do is deter
people from taking that route but
actually we do want to help people who
are fleeing uh for instance you know the
people we're helping coming from from
afghanistan of course 15 000 have
arrived but my question is
of course and i get that and it was a
fantastic job done by the raf as all of
my viewers will know but it's it's
against maritime law to turn boats
around so why is the um home secretary
even suggesting it so what i know is the
government home secretary is as you'd
expect i think looking at all the
options it's desperately difficult you
know i'm a kentucky including illegal
ones i know that migrants are turning up
on the beaches not very far from my
constituency people see them just
arriving
so so of course we should look at what
are the options and don't do what i
think the really important thing here is
the work that we're doing jointly with
the french and to you know support the
french to actually stop people leaving
in the first place okay well the french
are saying don't be ridiculous you can't
turn the boats around so we'll wait and
see um
what happens as far as that is concerned
let's move on to the topic that's very
close to your heart um nhs and social
care of course um
looking at the figures and my team
pointed out to me this morning uh that
the social care cap will help just five
percent of elderly people receiving care
is that right well what we're doing is
we are embarking on once in a generation
of forms of social care and just you
know give the context and remind viewers
i'm sure people know this but
governments for decades have talked
about reforming social care and we are
taking this big step and what we're
doing well let me just say so we know
all of that you know we've been talking
about it for three or four days so we're
aware of the background the question is
is it only helping five percent of
people that's not a number that i
recognize okay what i can say is that we
are putting in place that cap which
actually will give everybody peace of
mind of knowing that whether it's
somebody in their family or
going to need care in the near future or
in the longer term that you might need
care know that the the limit of the
amount that you would need to spend on
your care would be 86 000 pounds that
gives everyone peace of mind and we know
that at the moment one in seven people
receive care
have have a cost of over a hundred
thousand pounds for their care also as
part of this and this helps even more
people we're raising that the means test
the safety net in which you start
getting help so at the moment you don't
don't help until you only have about 23
000 pounds worth of assets we're raising
that to 100 000 pounds so more people
will get help okay i'm not never keen on
talking numbers because it's a bit
complicated in the morning when people
are getting the kids ready for school
etc but given that you brought up the
hundred thousand i'm told that the
government in fact your figures one in
seven people pay more than a hundred
thousand pounds for care so that means
six in seven people don't
so what you're gonna do for them so i
mean firstly to say the six and seven
they are worrying about it because you
never know so i don't know if you have
any family members with with dementia
many people do that i do all of my
family members are dead so no sadly not
i'm sorry kay
um but but
many people do and and the one of the
worries there is the uncertainty you
just don't know how much care they're
going to need and how long it's going to
take and therefore you can't plan for it
so knowing what the maximum is does and
help people plan uh for bills that might
fill in their way this is what you could
have won i mean you know six out of
seven people do not qualify for it i was
just coming so firstly i think actually
that peace of mind and i know from my
inbox as a constituency mp as well as
care minister this is something that
worries people a lot the other thing to
say is actually more than half of the
funding that we've just announced for
social care through our big reform is
actually to go into wider reforms of the
system so for instance more funding for
local authorities to help them pay a
fair rate for care at the moment people
who are self-funding paying their own
bills are often subsidizing
the people who have local authority
funded care which is often at a lower
rate we're going to give more funding to
local authorities so they can pay a fair
rate of care we're also going to be
putting over 500 million into workforce
training development to really support
our work and their care workforce is
just fantastic we want them to be more
valued have more training more career
development opportunities and this will
raise equality okay for everybody too
okay you talked about care workers um
there are i think 120 000 vacancies how
are you going to fill those
well we have been working with the
sector with skills for care which is the
organization which looks at the the
workforce particularly and works with
government on this
in the short term we have for instance
been doing marketing campaigns promoting
careers not as a
career um but we know that there is a
high turnover in care sector that's one
reason why we're putting this huge
amount of money the 500 million i just
mentioned into a skills and development
program i know from speaking to staff in
job centers one thing they say about
people uh and they talk about social
care jobs is well i don't see where the
career will get me i don't see a career
path so we want to build that kind of
career path so the opportunities for
people to gain the skills and really
feel valued in their work as they do it
doesn't help that you're forcing them to
have double jobs if they don't want to
i know this is a really difficult
question i mean the situation here is
you'll know your viewers will know that
care homes have had such a tough time in
this pandemic and that we have very
sadly seen many residents and care homes
die from cobalt because they are the
most vulnerable it has to be the right
thing to do to give them the best
because they were sent home from
hospitals when they had coverage um
because they weren't being tested and
this wasn't
this actually and there's been lots of
research done on that and actually this
wasn't the main source of covert getting
into care homes but the the reality is
um that you know one of the best ways we
can protect people living in care homes
is through making sure that staff are
vaccinated yes the ongoing testing and
staff are tested weekly as important as
well but vaccination is a really
important part of protecting those who
live uh in care homes now i've talked to
whether it's residents themselves or the
family members they really want uh the
family members living in care homes to
have the most protection and that's to
be looked after by staff for vaccinating
you acknowledge though that that number
120 000 that's just going to get worse
isn't it i know that the sector faces
huge numbers of vacancies and that there
is a lot
worse in the short term because those
are quite a lot of people who don't want
to be vaccinated well actually already
90 percent of uh workers and care homes
have been vaccinated there's still time
to get vaccinated and actually i'll say
to anyone i'd say to anyone watching
this today who hasn't yet been
vaccinated no go and get the jab for
care workers they've got until the 16th
of september
to have their first job and then still
that gives time before november the 11th
to have the second job so there's still
time going get vaccinated and then
you're both protecting yourself
and those that you look on what if they
don't
well it has to be the right thing to do
i know that there will be small numbers
who don't i mean there are med if
someone has a medical exemption a
medical reason for not being vaccinated
well that's a different matter of course
but what about the others that don't
what what will happen to them on the
11th now i mean the big question has to
be well if you don't want to get
vaccinated how can you continue how can
how could it be right to continue to
look after people are really vulnerable
from covert so they will lose their jobs
and that will make the issue of how many
people are employed and the number of
vacancies in care homes even worse yeah
i mean it will that is the actual fact
but that is why we're working
particularly
there is yes i acknowledge that in in in
areas where there are some care homes
where the vaccination rates are lower
some good number of got actually 100 all
of their staff are vaccinated but that's
not consistent that's why we're working
with local authorities and local
authorities in turner working
with care homes where the rates are
lower to really help their staff have
the confidence if they haven't had the
confidence get vaccinated yet to go and
get that job
just to labor this point and then we'll
move on to others there are 120 000 plus
vacancies at the moment that is going to
get worse after the 11th of november
because those who refuse to be double
vaccinated will lose their jobs well
we'll see we constantly see a level of
turnover in uh care homes in the social
care sector actually that's one reason
why we're doing this social care reforms
and as i mentioned that big investment
in the workforce building up people's
skills and the career path to try and
reduce the constant turnover you see of
people coming in and out of jobs in the
care sector we want to make it a
long-term career so that's the long-term
direction of travel what we're also
going to see uh next few weeks is some
people for instance coming off furlough
looking for jobs so there is movement in
the in the jobs market um and and so
actually there's a lot going on to make
sure that care homes do have the staff
that they need okay but just to make the
point if on the 11th of november people
who are presently working in care homes
don't have two vaccinations and a
certificate to prove that they're out of
work
well so the care home and the km have to
follow their own process we've given
guidance to the care homes about you
know how to
um support staff say yes or no ministry
there's no case or no question and i
think it's been it's quite of course i
recognize that there will be a number of
people who really really don't want to
get vaccinated um and the the caring
they're working for will be able to look
and see whether they can work for
instance not in the front line or not in
the care home but i know that those jobs
most jobs in caramel are on this on the
site in the premise and so for some
people we're continuing to work in a
camp won't be the right thing for them
but this has to be the right thing to do
to best protect those really vulnerable
people who live in care homes and at
most at risk from covered how do you
feel about nhs managers earning
something like 275 000 pounds a year
yeah it's a it's an an and uh i don't
know seeing the headline uh on that
today clearly uh i think they're taking
a step back
people working in the nhs and those kind
of roles are taking on a lot of
responsibility they're big jobs and
they're moving from having more senior
management than nhs to fewer through
doing this nhs reckons that it needs to
have that level of pay to have the right
people in those jobs but i do think you
know and the government keeps a really
close eye on making sure that nhs money
is spent carefully and appropriately
because we want is this much of the
funding to go
we want as much of the funding as
possible to go to the front line and for
instance for me
it looks like twice what you earn uh it
is significantly more uh than i earn so
i don't want to see uh nhs managers
being paid at unacceptable levels uh and
the nhs does need to be very careful
with because you almost started by
saying it was unacceptable well i think
i mean i completely recognize you know
your reaction the public's reaction
saying goodness look at that big number
of course we do want to have really top
people taking on the responsibility you
know driving forward some of the reforms
that we need in the nhs getting down the
backlog where we just voted through last
night 16 billion extra funding to help
the nhs get through the lack of
responsibility that you've got though in
your job and you know it's almost twice
your salary well well thank you for
pointing out
what i do in my job but i mean i think i
i i wouldn't compare them uh directly
like that is a very different line of
work but i mean what i really care about
is making sure right now
we get all those backlogs down the nhs
all those people waiting for over five
million people
waiting uh for operations for treatment
in the nhs at the moment we voted
through 60 million billion more for the
nhs last night to get down that back log
we want the nhs student to recover from
the from the pandemic clearly they are
still looking after people with covert
as well to get through this and make
sure that we have the nhs always there
for people when they need it beautiful
blue jacket on this morning how do you
feel about being called blue labor
actually i think we made a difficult
decision last night clearly and as a
conservative voting for a tax rise it's
not something you do
lightly we want people's money to be in
their pockets people successfully with
you tax risers so of course i don't want
us to raise tax but we had a really
difficult choice here said we had at the
moment we've got over five million
people on nhs waiting lists that
projected to potentially get to 13
million that could be about one in five
people waiting for an operation that's a
terrible position to be in coupled with
me as care minister we know we
desperately need to do social care
reform and governments for decades have
not been able to work out the way to to
fund that to move that forward so what
we've got here is a package that means
we can both treat all those people who
need treatment under the nhs and we can
embark on those once in a generation
social care reform it really is a very
beautiful jacket thank you very much
indeed for joining us on the programme
this morning thank you